Kate Upton opens up about her recent
sexual harassment claims
I appreciate this report so much and
reacts to her photoshoot wipeouts and
they love him but me an extreme
situation earlier this month the 25 year
old blonde beauty accused guest
co-founder Paul Marciano of sexual
harassment
now she's revealing why she's glad she
shared her story it's such an exciting
time for women because now we have a
platform to not allow the norm to be the
norm anymore and I'm just really excited
about this movement and I'm happy to
create a platform for other women to
speak their stories as well I think it's
women continuing to speak out and not
accept what what a beautiful venue our
Mordor and to expect being treated in a
professional way in a professional
setting
et spoke with Kate on Valentine's Day at
the 2018 Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
Issue launch party in New York City
she's featured in the magazine this year
but this time there was a bit of an
occupational hazard Illustrated it's
always an adventure for me I walked away
with only two scratches which I felt
very lucky about and I got a massage the
next day and it was all good rocks are
rocks no matter how beautiful the island
is so it always hurts when you fall on
them
[Music]